the world has been watching both the
geopolitical and
humanitarian crisis unfold between
israel and the palestinians in the gaza
strip in recent days
rockets from gaza are striking in israel
and israeli aircraft are pounding a wide
range of targets in gaza
civilians are dying and there's no clear
way to bring this dramatic escalation of
violence to a conclusion
in one sense this certainly is a new
phase in the decades-long conflict
between israel and the palestinians but
in other ways this outbreak is just more
of the same and a sign that the new
phase
some had hoped for in this long-running
conflict isn't at hand at
all first for starters the outbreak
shows it isn't possible to simply push
the conflict between israel and the
palestinians
to the back burner as the trump
administration tried the trump team
thought arab states had grown so tired
of the palestinian question
that they would merely sidestep
palestinian demands for their own state
and return of lands under israeli
control and concentrate instead on
making peace with israel
and confronting iran when you came into
office
iran was on the march because of your
leadership
iran is now on the run and that work to
some extent as bahrain united arab
emirates morocco and sudan
all established formal ties with israel
the hope was that the palestinian issue
would just fade in importance as these
sunni arab states
focus instead when confronting iran but
it's the new violence illustrates and as
diplomats have learned over the decades
the palestinian question has a way of
rearing its head over and over again
often when you least expect second this
crisis shows that it won't be as easy to
push israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu out of power as his critics at
home and abroad had hoped
after israel's fourth election in two
years recently mr netanyahu had been
unable to form a new government and his
main opponent
had been given the chance but the
current crisis is pushing domestic
politics aside
in israel and likely will prompt some
israelis to rally around their prime
minister in a time of duress
that may actually extend mr netanyahu's
long streak in power
and finally this crisis shows that it
isn't really possible at least not yet
to detach iran from the broader
palestinian problem
the extremist group hamas is firing the
rockets that are landing on israel and
iran
is the main international supporter of
hamas and it was iranian know-how that
largely helped hamas figure out
how to produce on its own the rockets it
is now firing
so the current crisis is showing that
the continued importance of the alliance
between iran and hamas
is as strong as ever and indeed this
could end up deepening that alliance
in some while the crisis is a dramatic
new escalation in tensions between
israel and the palestinians
it also is in many ways showing the old
dynamics are still in place
and may be even growing more entrenched
you